-Hey, finally guys,
it's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Pros and cons
and pros and cons and pros ♪
-Now, tonight,
we'll be taking a look
at the pros and cons of
JetBlue buying Spirit Airlines.
It was just announced
that JetBlue
is attempting to purchase
Spirit Airlines.
Yeah, this could mean a lot
of changes to the way we fly,
so let's take a look
at the pros and cons
of JetBlue
buying Spirit Airlines.
Here we go.
Pro --
JetBlue is offering
to buy Spirit Airlines
for $33 a share.
Con -- Spirit is like,
"Heck, you can take
the whole plane for $25."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- JetBlue promises
to bring all-new features
to Spirit planes.
Con -- like "pilots."
[ Laughter ]
You're gonna want those.
[ Applause ]
Pro -- now the two airlines
can join forces
and get back to doing
what they do best.
Con -- inventing new ways
to charge for luggage.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Uh, it's too small.
It's too small.
You gotta pay $5.
Small luggage."
[ Laughter ]
-"It's got a handle."
-"Yeah. Oh, it's a wallet.
Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
Pro -- JetBlue
is attempting the purchase
through a hostile takeover.
Con -- a hostile takeover
is how Spirit
describes
their boarding process.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I have Baltic!
I have Baltic!"
[ Applause ]
Pro -- JetBlue
wanted to sit down
with Spirit Airlines
and make a deal.
Con --
Spirit doesn't do "seats."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Everyone just standing, hold --
[ Laughter ]
Hold the pole.
-"Next.
Go ahead."
-"You can go ahead."
[ Laughter ]
"You can go ahead, if you want."
-"Wait, wait, wait."
-"You can fly it, if you want.
I don't care."
[ Laughter ]
-"Wait, stop.
Where'd you get those shoes?"
[ Laughter ]
-Pro -- Spirit stockholders
have a lot of questions.
Con -- like,
"How drunk was I
when I bought stock
in Spirit Airlines?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- Spirit's stock rose
in anticipation of the merger.
Con -- it's the first time
anything from Spirit
has ever gained altitude.
"Oh, yeah, we did it!"
[ Applause ]
And, finally, pro --
Spirit and JetBlue
will be combining forces.
Con --
to create "Spue Airlines."
There you have it.
Those are the "Pros and Cons."
We have a great show!